this is Matt a Spinelli associate editor  at GameSpot and I'm here to show you  footage a for honor season two's new  hero the Centurion this heavy melee  fighter is ideal for close quarters  combat being able to easily bypass an  opponent's defense by draining their  stamina with a series of staggering  blows it then seals the deal with an  array of devastating short-range  combination attacks and grabs that  intimidates its opponent giving them few  opportunities to retaliate how do you  think your favorite class will combat  the Centurion let us know in the  comments below and be sure to check out  our footage of four honors other new  hero the shinobi and while you're here  give us a thumbs up and subscribe to our  YouTube channel  ah  look  Oh  oh [ __ ]  Oh  okay  in the